where does youtube send new viewers in
canada so if you didn't know i'm in
canada i'm in a new place
if you can't tell that i'm in a new
place you need to refresh your screen
you need to hit the like button to act
as like a dgos button so in like an old
crt
screen you know you would hit the dcos
and it would like the magnets would just
reset i don't know what they did but
apparently
if you press that button enough it could
blow up the whole thing and i've had a
crt blow up on me before
okay so me and my brother this is really
tangential but me and my brother
we blew up an entire uh crt monitor
uh from another room entirely uh we were
actually in the room over
um we were playing with an open like
electrical socket i don't recommend this
this is a bad idea
so we had a paper clip and uh we
this is a true story it's not a lie this
is an absolute true story
okay so like okay electrical socket you
take off the front panel it's all
exposed
on the two sides of it you know is like
i don't know
we just figured something would happen
so we took a paper clip and we uh
jammed it in there this dead true i
might be dead this all might be a
hallucination from this one moment in my
life
but i i took it and i i jammed it in
there and then the lights all flickered
out
and then in the other room we heard a
[ __ ]
like an explosion because it was an
explosion and then i
heard my dad go what the [ __ ]
this is when i was like five or
something and then me and my brother we
ran another and we peek over
and there's just smoke billowing out at
the top of the crt
[Laughter]
i don't think we told i don't think we
told our dad
what the hell we did i think we took
that
we just got that a secret that is 100 a
true story that is not a lie at all
anyway i'm out of quarantine by the way
if you if you can't tell
you need to reset your monitor at the
risk of blowing it the hell up by
pressing the like button and de-glossing
it anyway so the canadian government
will be coming after me shortly
that's not the point of this the point
of this is
where does youtube send you
in canada it's been about a year since i
did the last one
and actually it's been over a year and
so i kind of
want to make this an annual thing to see
where exactly youtube's focus is in
terms of new viewers so i'm here on
youtube's front page
it's a completely incognito thing i
haven't even opened youtube
where i'm at let alone on this computer
in a while so
this should be very new very canadian
so let's take a look first thing to
notice youtube music student plan
discount it thinks i'm a student
does it think i'm a student i know
there's a university near here but i
didn't know that this was like a student
thing i imagine this is just all part of
youtube premium i know that they're
doing oh see
youtube car youtube car youtube car nada
that's proof i'm in canada so with
youtube uh
what the freaking [ __ ] is going on with
those lips i
hate it it's fine it's fascinating you
know ss sniper wolf uh definitely has
been
a staple in all of these like absolutely
all of these
uh reviews of where youtube sends new
viewers we've got
random short funny video probably we've
got
music which is interesting youtube's
doing a push for like these shorts they
want to do tick tock style like short
vertical videos so you're seeing a lot
more of these type of videos get pushed
and a lot of channels that are popping
up that are based around this type of
content
alone now now i don't know if they're
pushing it as hard as they were just a
few months ago but there definitely is a
trend to get these types of videos out
there
which in general just leads to a lot of
people ripping content from tick tock
and then just slapping their own logo on
it
and putting it up on youtube which is
kind of the essence of the internet in
terms of content anyway
there's a lot of people that are
creating content but there's a lot of
people also stealing content and putting
it everywhere to try to get some profit
out of that
wherever they go uh we got some kind of
floating highway
thing that's kind of cool probably like
a sketch probably sketch
about autotune something like that
gordon ramsay gordon ramsay's always
around mr beast
yeah okay trending okay billy i let's
just release the new video
trailer so what i'm looking for here is
like the the kind of like
dividing line between mainstream tv
entertainment things that were on
youtube which i think last time was a
very big
feature of a lot of the videos that were
pushed on youtube there was a lot of
them
this is actually the first one i've seen
there but also here's insider news
so obviously the big difference between
this year and last year is that
covet 19 happened so a lot of the things
are actually pushing
news a lot of news stories are cropping
up to the front
and because a lot of people want to know
what's going on in the world mark robert
some kind of stream maybe like a
premiere we got movie clips
that's typical um let's actually look at
the the
the front page kind of divvied up a
little differently because of the way
you can see more try guys chess chess
has actually gotten big in popularity
there was a lot of people that were
trying out chess
on twitch getting that into it because
suddenly that became big and i
i don't think it's actually fallen out
of it because for a lot of people chess
is very universal
chess is like appealing to tons of
people so oh yeah there's gonna do more
dexter stuff
i i kind of like dexter but you know
obviously the end of the
show kind of fell apart so who knows
what's gonna happen you got that
the the the um that show i forget what
the name of that show is
but that's popular netflix whatever that
is some kind of repainting thing
i don't know what this block is what is
this block is this covet 19 this is not
kovan 19
this is this is not anything music music
music and then peter parker versus
flash whatever that is and then covet 19
which you could
you could close i guess option hidden a
lot more music
a lot more news here we go news okay all
right
dumbest answer okay that's tv music
this music music like coco melon
there's music there is just so
much more music in fact like at the top
of here
youtube music was being pushed is it
something music is at the top of this
why music so hard i mean i get it a lot
of people do turn to youtube for
music but i wonder why i wonder why
recently there's probably been a bigger
push
this is not the same as i mean there's
always been a presence of music on
on youtube don't get me wrong like music
videos live
and thrive on youtube but these channels
that are like
compilations of music like i don't know
do you own all of that like these
these uh live stream channels that start
off from like the uh the lo-fi hip-hop
radio which is like the staple of it
from lo-fi girl like this has been like
the staple of it for so long but when it
comes down to
copycats of those there are just about
music
things for every single one of
every single type of music that you
could possibly
like appreciate best of hans zimmer i
mean
hell yeah but also i can't play any of
this
or else my my channel is going to get
banned
see look mr b shorts same thing that's
what i was talking about people getting
into these short
vertical video content it is trying to
go down the tick tock route
which like of course they would you know
google staples like copying other
people's
uh tech and just making it their own i
mean that's everyone in the tech
businesses that's what they do but just
like
look music music music canada canada
there we go finally something canadian
all right you know what since i'm in
canada let's go with the canada road
trip
let's see where this sends me see how
quick i get to uh
wow this is good stuff
i mean that is very impressive that's
quite a road trip
it's about how much i did when i drove
from la to cincinnati
so it's about the same all right boring
okay so
what's what's funny though what i just
realized is the thumbnail for this video
uh lixian can you pull that up like the
thumbnail for the video that i just
pulled up here
it had a certain look to it every one of
these thumbnails
actually has the same kind of theme
to it do you notice that like kind of
blue sky
blue tones road like it's divided up
into a top and a bottom half in terms of
like landscape
the horizon line is like right towards
the middle or at least the lower third
now i don't know what that has to do
with anything it probably doesn't have
to do with anything because
all of these are kind of like the same
vein so naturally when you get the same
type of video you're going to get kind
of a similar thumbnail
but honestly these are startlingly
similar
in terms of that i don't know if that's
part of the algorithm that's trying to
identify what people want not just on
the title and the content they're in but
also on similarity of thumbnail
because i mean if you think about it
they have done a lot more in terms of
like
algorithmical picking of automatic
thumbnails for videos they've done that
if you've uploaded a video to youtube
you notice that it's it's
auto-generated thumbnails are getting a
little bit smarter on getting the best
or at least the most differentiated
image in terms of uh the auto thumbnail
not that people do that anyway
but just look at these these are all the
same best road trip to canada
same here very similar style i mean very
pretty one thing i will say about being
up in here in canada i have actually
gotten a chance to drive around is that
it's very very pretty
like god it's pretty up here i'm just
gonna go back to the front page see how
this changed up my entire adventure
oh there we go it has really locked me
into
traveling this dude norway australian
italian alps that
dancing stuff happening montreal
undisputed four boycott
you know trending has changed whoa
wait a minute what the hell
[Music]
whoa what the hell no that's weird okay
if you don't get why that's weird you'll
understand that that's very weird thank
you youtube premium i actually have it
already
the trending page has not changed before
as far as i know the trending page has
been kind of static
because obviously the idea is that
trending like you have different
categories of trending
but usually trending means that day
these are the most popular videos
these are different videos which means
that it's
not really trending it's trending
but also just a recommended for me
because the top is always like
recommended and or pick up where you
left off in another video
which i think is a great feature and
that's very good because honestly when i
go to youtube now this is where i get
most of my content from
i get it from these eight videos here
whereas trending i never really go to
because it's always the same thing
and usually videos that i'm not
interested in but the fact that this has
changed
means that there's a fundamental
difference in the way that youtube
categorizes their trending videos
and maybe subdivides it into different
like categories for people based on what
they like
weird lion asking dog for forgiveness
okay well that's kind of cool
fine but i'm hoping it's a situation
where i don't understand the dynamics
and everything is totally fine
i don't like it okay how's that changed
okay so now we got animal videos
all right so this is it's different
again
because i remember that was number two
before but now now there's different
things
what is that what is any of this now
there's gaming stuff in here
it's changed you may not think this is
as groundbreaking as like
as like i do but for as long as i've
been on youtube the trending page has
been uniform
it has been the same for everyone pretty
much
based on like what day that video went
up this
is extremely weird why would they do
this i mean i get why
they might i'm sure this is going to go
fair
camera look at this it's 2007. this is
an old video
this is like original youtube and it's
popping up here i've noticed that before
like for some reason on my channel meow
has been recommended like crazy
non-stop for a good long time meow now
has been like
my most watched video every day for the
past few months straight
and i don't know why but it's just like
youtube for some reason some
algorithmical changes will start to kick
up
older popular videos i don't know why i
don't know where
even older not popular videos i'm sure
that you guys have seen videos that crop
up in your recommended feeds
that seem completely out of the blue
don't have that many views but for some
reason are getting pushed all around and
everywhere you go every other video
it'll be like the same video be staring
you
in the face and you were tempted to
click on it more and more until finally
you do
and then you look down in the comments
section everyone's like why the hell did
youtube recommend me this video
and it's like not even a thing where
it's like you want to see it because
clearly
i didn't click on it the first time i
saw it but youtube just kept
recommending it to me
until i clicked on it so anyways this
looks unsafe
all right this looks unsafe yeah a
little bit
yeah that seemed extremely unsafe okay
south korean soldier
encounters australia's most dangerous
wildlife okay so we got soldier road
trip
puppy okay pretty much the top three are
all the videos that i looked at
we have road trip we have dog and we
have
the soldier gun and then we have gun gun
gaming is still trying to be pushed here
which is weird that a live channel is
being pushed up on my recommended
and it's even weirder because a live
channel is not only being recommended
but it's for a category that i have not
yet clicked on
although to be perfectly honest not many
people are going live in other
categories gaming is pretty much the top
one for that
and it's different again it's different
again it really wants to push up these
gaming videos it really wants like to
pop out the first one to be different
that's a great thumbnail by the way
here we go canadian artillery wake up
yeah this gotta be good
this is what we're looking for how could
you just fall asleep like that with
everyone around you anyway i don't get
that
i would never be able to
[Laughter]
[Music]
very funny now it's just gonna think i
want soldier videos
which is not entirely true ah god there
it is soldier soldier soldier soldier oh
sorry police not soldier
counter reeves yeah that's all it is now
and trending is different
now i've destroyed it i've destroyed my
algorithm because it's just nothing but
it's nothing but soldiers and guns stuff
ah i'm never going to be able to get
away from this
oh yes oh my god this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] what is that
what is this garbage
what is this goddamn garbage what is
this you just got
shanked what is this
you just you got cheated on now you're
gonna destroy an army of clones
i don't get it
god mobile ads jesus christ mobile ads
are so terrible
so unbelievably terrible
this makes it better who's better
[Music]
this is very cute that's very cute okay
is that fixed is this it's just gonna be
soldiers and
dogs that's all it's gonna be i will
admit though the trending page seems to
be the same videos
it's just a different organization of
the same videos i wonder if i go to the
actual trending page if that will
show anything else okay no it's it's
actually different videos
this is so weird this is so weird
so what i'm discovering here is
the youtube recommended page what it's
very good at
is custom recommendations based on what
i
click on that's what it's always been
good at but it seems to be
even better because i remember a while
ago when you would do that it would
eventually lead you down a rabbit hole
that
led to conspiracy videos that's the
first reason why i
wanted to do a video like this just to
see how quickly i could get down to
conspiracy videos but it seems like that
has actually gone away again
oh i remember this video there's a good
one but like when it comes to that oh
mute this looks he and mute this there's
no way
i actually made a stupid ass parody
video on this one
[Music]
what a [ __ ] good video like just like
it's so weird number one
effective and it's it's an ad obviously
so whatever but just like
it's what a [ __ ] good video that's
great oh [ __ ] gus johnson hell yeah i
love this video
now i'm just getting what i would do not
not necessarily a new user
i'm actually kind of surprised that it's
just well no that makes sense because i
did gun video
you know kind of like a silly parody
video buster
and this is just oh hey couldn't help
but notice you're trespassing
on my land sorry i was just hiking
through i didn't know this was private
property
best get to stepping son i could just
get off if you need me to i'm sorry i
didn't know that i'm doing a lot of
yammering
but unbeknownst to you you're speaking
your final words you don't need to
brandish that weapon it's i'm
not gonna hurt you well sounds to me
like we got him you want me to watch
smart ass on our hands you're ejecting a
lot of shells there yup
you're not gonna have any left to shoot
me would you just say to me it's like
the 12th shell
little [ __ ] you already got one in the
chamber i've seen like 36 shells go
through that gun
don't need them do you have any left in
there all right i've had it up to here
uh oh oh geez take this
i can just leave you're not even yeah
i'm shooting at you now
is that even a real gun yeah there's
like zero recoil to that gun
dude you're not even coming close to me
here alakablam i don't understand the
physics of this you're gonna want to get
well all right dude how many shells do
you have in that gun
i got 57 more goddamn rounds in this
four round magazine i love this video
this is so good if you haven't seen this
jesus christ
why why why have you not seen this is so
good how's that changed up my entire
dynamic
oh look it's a freaking parody though
yeah no we've really entered the realm
of my recommendations
i i actually got to give it to youtube
here this is exactly what i deserve
we got nazi baddies sketch we got
parody of the video i just watched we
got military video we got dog video we
got
another parody of that's or a derivative
of the same people that made that one
volvo trucks
we got strange soldier antics we got
like whatever this gun thing and then
dueling banjos with music just get the
music in here
like it is it is interesting honestly i
i'm not i i have no complaints about
this
this has been very effective in terms of
getting me
videos that would keep me watching
naturally
i'm like interested in a significant
amount of these videos even this shirt
video where the hell is this going to
come from this is actually
how i fold church like it's a good way
to do it
bam very easy it's a very simple way
yeah no it's a good way to
fold the shirt that's how i do but like
like honestly this
is very good this is much better
than what i imagined what the frick is
[Music]
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is
that is hilarious that is very how do
you only have this
probably not their video but whatever
that is amazing again this is i am in a
different country
this is a computer that i do not watch
youtube regularly on i am not signed in
i am incognito like this is new but
based on what
i would pick and that's what i've done
i've picked what i would pick
it's gotten me to videos that i
typically watch anyway it is
very intelligent like it's scary
intelligent it should not be this good
at
letting me know what i want but here we
are
god it's videos that i would normally
watch look it's like the official
strongman thing i've
i think this is actually how i got into
doing that or watching like strongman
videos because it's just very
very interesting this is crazy and also
makes me scared
but also this is probably the best
iteration of
youtube's algorithm that i've seen since
i started doing this a few years ago
okay i think that's going to do it for
this one um so in canada maybe it's just
canada you know maybe canada has better
recommendations than america does
maybe that's all the lesson that should
be taken away from this but hey
you know fun video if you want to see in
the history of youtube's algorithm what
i've explored where youtube sends you
viewers
there's going to be a video he
recommended boom
something like that please go watch that
because otherwise your hands will be
your fate will be in the hands of
youtube's big strong hands
and though their hands are big and
strong and very capable apparently
and and capable of getting you exactly
where you need to want to go
trust me instead i'm a very trustworthy
man and i'm not a computer
i will not take your data and i will not
sell it
trust me with your data actually i don't
even read your data i don't even know
what your data is
anyway the goddamn lithium it was
probably too oh the video was probably
too long it wouldn't have shown up there
trim this all down looks gonna make it
work i'm gonna get out of here and end
it